إصدارنا الجديد هو ios 15.
أولاً ، ميزة تجعل مكالمات الوجه
تبدو وكأنك جالس في
نفس الغرفة
الآن تنتشر أصوات أصدقائك
لتبدو وكأنهم قادمون من
الاتجاه الذي يتم وضعهم فيه
مكالمة الفيديو
عندما تريد أن ترى كل وجه في
الغرفة ، يمكنك الآن تشغيل عرض الشبكة
مما يمنحك طريقة أخرى لعرض
مكالماتك الجماعية ،
فنحن نقدم وضع عمودي حيث
أخذنا
الإلهام من الصور الشخصية المذهلة على iPhone.
إنشاء روابط فيس تايم
الآن ، يمكنك إنشاء رابط
لمكالمة فيس تايم ومشاركتها في
أي مكان يمكن لأصدقائك الذين
يستخدمون أجهزة أندرويد وويندوز استخدام رابط فيس تايم
للانضمام إلى المكالمة
مباشرة من متصفحهم عندما تكون في
مكالمة وجهًا لوجه ، انتقل
إلى تطبيق البث  واضغط على تشغيل
وازدهر
، تشاهد أنت وأصدقاؤك
نفس الفيديو
متزامنًا تمامًا ،
ويمكنك استخدام مشاركة الشاشة لتصفح قوائم zillow
مباشرة مع زملائك في السكن المستقبليين
أو التباهي بحركة صعبة في y
لعبتنا المفضلة وهي تعمل
عبر أجهزة Apple عندما تستخدم
لا تزعج
حالتك يتم عرضها تلقائيًا
في الرسائل
عندما تصل إلى شخص
أشار إلى أنه لا يريد أن
يزعجك ،
سيتم تذكيرك في تلك اللحظة وللحصول
على  الرسائل العاجلة حقًا ،
هناك طريقة للوصول إليها ، لذا فنحن
نجلب بطاقات الهوية إلى محفظة Apple
هذا الخريف ، وستقوم فقط بمسح
رخصة القيادة أو معرف الحالة في مشاركتنا توضح
أنه من السهل أن تكون معلومات هويتك
الآن في المحفظة